okay i want to uh talk to you about some
amazing things number one
snow white what can you tell us
congratulations it's so i'm the father
of a six-year-old
ah that's a one yeah but my kids are
very very excited as well it's uh it's
it's all new news to
we just broke out with this news and i'm
very very very excited and looking
forward
to to play the evil queen
mirror mirror on the wall
first of all i'm excited about the fact
that this is like an icon character
um and i'm excited to do to make to
create a you know an iconic
uh villain character in my own voice in
my own you know we cannot wait to see it
thank you what are you wearing today
i'm wearing a louis v
i watched this film about two hours ago
and my goodness does it answer on all
the levels it's so great ryan rock and
gal i've coined you guys the big three
what do you think fans are gonna love
most about seeing you guys together in
this
i think
wow it's hard to say just one thing but
i think the reason why i love this movie
so much
is because of the twists and turns it's
very surprising it's funny
and it's filled with action it's like
such a fun movie did you have a good
time playing this sort of cheeky
mysterious darker character yes i did
it was refreshing thank you it was such
a
i was looking forward to do something uh
different and more
easily and
you know villainy and uh yeah the bishop
is um definitely gave me that yeah for
sure
netflix has said that this is one of
their most expensive films do you feel
any pressure to deliver or make it a hit
because of that i always feel the
pressure to make something good
not just because of the amount of money
that's being put into the movie but also
because the amount of effort it takes a
village that all of the people involved
are putting in it
so i always wish and hope and aspire to
do something that people back at home
will enjoy and you do every time we we
love watching you now i want to ask
wonder woman black adam or deadpool who
wins in a fight wonder woman
you're 100 right thank you i know
ryan ryan said wonder woman as well and
he said
he said the rock was going to pick black
adam but you'd have a little more
humility and might pick him
but i'm just going to go with uh wonder
woman
i'm just going to go with wonder woman
so
deadpool deadpool
yes
deadpool but we all really know it's
wonder woman exactly
[Music]